hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
Donald M Humphrey we are going to watch
today a music video slash three boys boy
I'll kill you that way
official Backstreet Boys parody song
this comes from patron Lance door at our
patreon we do weekly Q&A TV show
reactions and John on the regular covers
music videos because most of music video
reactions get blocked in fact this
probably has a really good chance of
getting blocked anyway we're gonna do it
for Lance cuz one of the reward chairs
of whatever video your request was
definitely doing put him on the youtubes
Lance is a hard-working father and loyal
boyfriend I don't think he's married
he's a firefighter up in Canada and last
time I was talking with this guy on last
time but if through the course of
conversing with him got to learn a lot
about his backstory in his personal life
I'm gonna divulge all that right here he
had a really kind of interesting
upbringing and it's cool when you get to
meet someone who turns into the kind of
man you are today Lance a hard-working
guy there's a loyal father loyal lover
and is also a person who is able to take
pain and turn it into something good to
let go of something and grow from it so
I highly admire you how to respect you
and I appreciate you being a supporter
here he ever leave our patreon I take
all those words back oh yeah and your
piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
call me goes haha wow I'm gonna like
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I collect Krishna
[Music]
food
[Music]
a lot Leatherface get in there it was
pretty objective that
[Music]
no chance of the water
[Music]
I hate water too
sleep with me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I hope they kill all the fans yeah I
really wanted to kill my head police is
the ultimate owner
[Music]
for ballot
I just wish Freddy could play with his
claws
[Music]
I don't think it's harsh race I know
rude is people to see it oh I don't kill
the fans damn they've sold out man
they've sold out for the love of the
fans the fans love they're like we're
not gonna kill you anymore because we're
on top that would have been the perfect
ending oh yeah do a total tone shift to
just have them fight yeah pounding
goring and actually people screaming
Karl the music like yeah oh well still
that is that was really making me laugh
a hell of a lot you know I admired these
musical parodies yeah this is really
funny since it's not really freaking
funny I feel like they should do a
follow-up and include jigsaw in there
Little Billy puffy Billy the puppy yeah
you could just do a revolving door of
different horror icons yeah pretty soon
if they you know make the writing like
super distinct enough that all the
characters like bring a very distinct
tone of voice then you could start
mixing yeah over time and then you have
a whole series it never has to end if I
were to dissect this I would say that
it's it's a clever - commentary on how
real killers like people like Ted bunny
and stuff will get like fangirls people
is sending them mail and stuff like that
waiting outside of holding signs
sometimes it's protest sometimes it's
love same thing with these you know
famous movie killer famous because they
get these fan bases a lot of fangirls
over them a fan would yell off fangirls
- people pick their favorite one yeah
that being said I don't think that's at
all what they were doing it's a back
slash make sense for them all to maybe
make a boy band in this weird yeah
but ya know like it just it does totally
just by existing kind of comment on the
fact that we do have you know like a
little slash pack of killers of that era
that they're all the tight every year
universe sounds like the Titans of
horror
you know it's yeah yeah Jason the
Leatherface they are a boy band who just
all did solo stuff
except for this once I was bummed too
they cut off Leatherface actually yeah
because I when I started mixing up I
thought that was clever because when
Michael Myers was singing I thought that
part sure though it's is all a joke
Jason something really wants to sing so
was this so strange and the [ __ ] he was
saying well Michael Mayer started
singing to me because we're just coming
off of Halloween I was like he doesn't
have a voice right it's kind of weird
but choice either so I can't really make
that complaint well it's the I think
it's the fact that the guy who's singing
for Michael is doing a lot of extra like
vocalizations the other guys are
basically just singing the main melody
of the song he's like improvising yeah
so it's like calling attention to the
voice of Michael in a way because I
thought it was odd to a bit but when it
came to Leatherface singing and he had a
southern accent country I was like oh
that's Marty Texas Chainsaw Massacre
yeah but it was like what that makes 100
percent so Freddy cut him off I was a
little bit bummed out by that because I
was so into it I was like the whole
thing I was so into it I was like ah
damn the way Freddy has killed people
over time I'm like what would you object
to that it seems like something that you
would have probably done to some you
know Backstreet Boys very 90s and of
course all these four icons rely on so
much nostalgia and then with the
Backstreet Boys you know we're entering
so much 90s nostalgia this is such like
a club like in terms of the conception
of this and I don't know if it's
intentional all this like brilliance of
nostalgia being infused and what cuz I
didn't realize this video only came out
a few days ago until while we're filming
and then I saw the date here is I
thought oh this must be a really old
thing yeah yes Backstreet Boy is making
fun of these guys anymore you know and
to see how well this video is doing
first off congrats to you guys on the
success of this video it's brilliantly
done it's really well shot where you
shot in the woods perfectly Beach
they're moving like pop stars I thought
was so brutal like oh yeah the white is
so back three moves a lot pop stars yeah
and then also like I love the hit like
Michael's dancing is doing really good
stuff throughout this really tickle be
like like and it is just like so much
fun
yeah while it
is also totally for Halloween time what
Ghostface drop Sydney's well and that
was an example of a you know like a
vocal touch that they added that I
thought really worked a line was the
like you know phone story on his voice
and stuff like that hey the merkins I
want you to know you have dug yourself a
hole here you are gonna be forced to now
make so many parodies every time you do
one people will be like oh it wasn't
this forty years before the next one
where you get Chucky and jigsaw together
okay I started running out of like the
great ones Leslie Vernon Victor Crowley
me start getting Jack girl Haley's
Freddy in there yeah just like conjuring
universe from all the different sequels
we got forever it's not gonna be as
funny but people are still gonna demand
that you keep doing it deeper deeper
cuts man that's the goal they look like
you wanted to say something oh if I did
I don't remember it I was talking about
him digging a hole and you were like you
did your John I have a thought thing
where you go you know that who's digging
a hole I said something you're like oh
damn I hope it comes back to me before
we finish if I had if I had a thing
instead of the ball that pops up on Mac
I wish I could have you just going I
don't know but it was a good point all
right this is great thank you so much
for making this is amazing anyway and
thanks Lance for recommending it let's
get in sync one next yeah Oh God you've
dug yourself a hole
you guys can't subscribe to the reject
nation please click that notification
Bell subscribed the merkins at a four
million something views and we have a
hundred three thousand subscribers now a
hundred three thousand and one that's
what it was their news this wasn't
actually a very good argument or
anything do you know what a Birkin is no
they're named after like crotch wigs Oh
yeah it's like when they put on actors
when they have to get naked for TV shows
oh it's right yeah yeah my girlfriend's
newer one yeah yeah yeah yeah when you
need it to look like you know you're in
the 70s again yeah yeah yeah you know
you like a like a burly you know rugged
guy like an outdoorsman type working up
click that notification bell you can
check us out patron and buy a real
rejects brand merkins we're gonna see
like early